- We are back
and 40 years ago, y'all,
the mother-daughter duo Naomi and Wynonna
broke ground in the country
music scene as The Judds.
They earned Grammys,
CMA Awards, ACM Awards,
and we just love them so much.
They were all set to do
a reunion tour in 2022
when, tragically, Naomi Judd passed away.
To celebrate her momma's legacy,
and to raise awareness
about mental illness,
Wynonna Judd has released a new album
called "A Tribute to The Judds."
The artists who've contributed
are some of the best,
Dolly Parton, Lainey Wilson, Jelly Roll,
and our next guest.
Performing The Judd's classic,
"Cry Myself to Sleep,"
ooh, you ain't ready for this,
give it up for Wynonna
Judd and Trisha Yearwood!
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
♪ Oh, oh I tried so hard ♪
♪ You know I can't do more ♪
♪ It's the turn of the card ♪
♪ It's the close of the door ♪
♪ The lies you told ♪
♪ You know they hurt so deep ♪
♪ So I'll go home ♪
♪ And cry myself to sleep ♪
- Woo!
♪ Day after day ♪
♪ You've been treatin' me bad ♪
♪ My friends come up and they say ♪
♪ Why do you take all that ♪
♪ 'Cause it's makin' me moan ♪
♪ Oh, and it's making me weep ♪
♪ So I'll go home, home ♪
♪ And I'll cry myself to sleep ♪
♪ Yeah, you play at love
like a child plays games ♪
♪ Oh, one day I'm in then I'm out again ♪
♪ You change the rules ♪
♪ And I just can't win ♪
♪ It's broken me now ♪
♪ So I give in, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
- Woo! Get it, girl.
♪ Ooh ♪
♪ Worse ♪
♪ But I don't know what ♪
♪ Oh, I gave to you ♪
♪ Everything that I got ♪
♪ Oh, oh, so take this heart ♪
♪ Or what's left to keep ♪
♪ And I'll go home, home ♪
♪ And I'll cry myself to sleep ♪
♪ Home, home ♪
♪ Cry myself to sleep ♪
♪ All I do is cry ♪
♪ Oh, I cry ♪
♪ Come on ♪
♪ Myself to sleep ♪
♪ Oh yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Cry myself to sleep ♪
♪ Cry, cry, cry, cry, cry ♪
♪ Cry ♪
♪ Myself to sleep ♪
♪ Mm, mm ♪
♪ Cry ♪
♪ Cry myself to sleep ♪
(Trisha laughs)
♪ Woo-ooh ♪
♪ Oh, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Cry ♪
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
- One more time, y'all.
Woo! We were blessed.
Let's here it for Wynonna
Judd and Trisha Yearwood,
two of the greatest singers ever.
As we honor National
Mental Wellness Month,
remember to pick up "A
Tribute to The Judds"
wherever you get your music.
A portion of the proceeds
go to the National Alliance
on Mental Illness Tennessee.
We will be right back with
What I'm Liking as well.